in their quest to bully everyone in any
position of prominence and to publicly
ripping president Trump the media have
set their sights on New England Patriots
quarterback Tom Brady Brady became a
campaign issue when in September 2015
somebody took a photo of a make America
great again had in his locker and said
he hoped Trump became president Trump
repeatedly referenced Brady's support on
the campaign trail - then after becoming
president Trump bragged that Brady had
called him to congratulate him
all of this prompted USA Today sports
writer Nancy armored write a piece
demanding Brady denounce Trump quote Tom
Brady no longer gets a pass on his
friendship with Donald Trump not after
this weekend when the country boiled
over in rage and indignation at Trump's
decision to turn America's back on
refugees he thinks the friendship should
be off-limits but it doesn't work that
way
if you stake out a position you need to
own it Brady might not agree with
Trump's views or his policies but in
refusing to publicly disavow Trump's
actions Brady is giving tacit
endorsement to both Trump and that chaos
he created Brady inserted himself into
the national firestorm he can't be
surprised that people want to know more
Brady for his part has refused to talk
about Trump he said I'm not talking
politics at all because I just want to
focus on the positive aspects of this
game and my teammates and the reason why
we're here which is smart given that
football is a team sport and those who
have supported Trump have cut him under
public fire from their own teammates and
players for doing so when Rex Ryan
endorsed Trump created this huge
firestorm this follows on the heels of
the left's attempts to bully Taylor
Swift into more clearly endorsing the
women's March force companies to reject
Trump's executive orders rip uber for
the crime of providing people at JFK
Airport rides the destroy sage Steel for
having temerity to want to make her
flight and blackball curt schilling for
likening radical jihadist to nazis this
is ideological hectoring the phrase the
social fabric voting for Donald Trump
doesn't mean you have to defend every
session he makes any more than voting
for Bill Clinton meant you were
answerable for his perjury and turning
celebrities into moral guides is always
a risky business given their regular
penchant for immorality in any case
listen
America is rooting against Tom Brady by
polling data in the Super Bowl but that
will change if the media decides to
declare him the enemy for holding a
political opinion of which they do not
approve i'm ben shapiro this is the
venture hero show
okay so we're gonna get to the so called
Monday night massacre in a second we're
gonna debunk some myths about what just
happened with Donald Trump firing the
acting Attorney General and what exactly
happened there but first we have to
thank one of our great advertisers bull
and branch so bull and branch is one of
my favorite advertisers truly because
and I bought I think three sets of extra
sheets from them if you're somebody who
has a tough time sleeping then one of
the reason you may be having a tough
time sleeping is because the sheets
you're sleeping on that you don't really
think about are just not comfortable you
think they're comfortable because
they're soft but it turns out they don't
breathe or you think that they're
comfortable even though they actually
are just the tarp that you bought from
the local gas station which is how I
used to buy sheets I mean if you're like
me you don't know anything that sheets
and you're like okay well thread count
that's what matters thread count no
thread count is not what matters quality
of the cotton is what is what matters
quality of the weave is what matters
bolon branch is the best they are the
best I love their product and right now
if you go to bull and branch calm and
you use promo code Ben you get 50 bucks
off your first set of sheets bull and
branch calm today for 50 bucks off your
first set of sheets luxury sheets you
know that this is the sort of thing that
makes you feel rich I've always said to
my wife that it's it's the little things
in life that cost maybe a little more
than you normally would spend that make
you feel rich for a long time not the
kind of big expenditures you know and
having a great set of sheets is one of
those things that makes you feel wealthy
because you sleep better and because
every time you get into the into bed you
feel SuperDuper comfortable and that is
certainly true of all and branch sheets
it's y3x presidents and in the case of
Bill Clinton their lovers presumably
sleep on Boland branch sheets and so you
should check that out bolt and branch
comm promo code Ben you got 50 bucks off
your first set of sheets truly great
company and very excited to be
associated with them make sure they use
promo code Ben when you order your sheet
so you know so they know that we sent
you okay so we begin of course with the
big story of the morning and of last
evening which is Donald Trump's
late-night firing of the assistant or
the acting Attorney General so remember
Loretta Lynch is now gone she's resigned
and Jeff Sessions has not yet been
approved president Trump's pick for
attorney general and that leaves this
lady in Sally Yates Oh Sally Yates was
the person who's the acting Attorney
General and she released a statement
yesterday in which she suggested that
she was not going to enforce or even
defend in court the the Trump
Immigration and Refugee Executive Order
and her statement really had nothing to
do with the law her statement was just
grandstanding it was her saying I'm not
gonna defend this law cuz I don't think
it's right here's what she actually said
she said I am responsible for ensuring
that the positions we take in court
remain consistent with this institution
solemn obligations who always seek
justice and stand for what is right well
no actually that is not your job your
job is to defend everything under the
law meaning that if there's no
reasonable defense of the statute that's
one thing if there's no reasonable
defense of an executive order that's why
it's unconstitutional that's one thing
but she doesn't even make that argument
her statement basically just says I'm
gonna do what I think is right as Acting
Attorney General well no that's not your
job the Attorney General serves at the
pleasure of the president swears an oath
to the Constitution if you're not
claiming that the executive order is
unconstitutional which you can't since
it's not the executive order is not
unconstitutional immigrants to the
country do not have any rights under the
Constitution meaning if you're not yet a
citizen if you're just trying to
emigrate or if you're just a refugee you
don't have rights under the Constitution
of the United States so clearly this is
not unconstitutional Yates says instead
I just don't feel like doing it which
makes her a hero on the left
so Donald Trump immediately tweets out
the Democrats are delaying my cabinet
picks for purely political reasons we'll
talk about that in a second they have
nothing going but to obstruct now I have
an Obama AG and then Trump fired her
right so the administration on the
firing sounds like it was dictated by
Trump personally I mean it really is
like it's in full trumpian language you
can tell I mean you really it goes the
acting Attorney General Sally Yates has
betrayed the Department of Justice by
refusing to enforce a legal order
designed to protect the citizens of the
United States this order was approved as
to forum and legality by the Department
of Justice Office of Legal Counsel miss
Yates is an Obama administration
appointee who's a week on borders and
very very weak on illegal immigration
that's the part that sounds like Trump
and then he goes on talking about it's
serious time to get serious about
protecting our country he calls for
tougher vetting measures for individuals
he says it's reasonable and necessary to
protect our country
you know repeating himself so it but you
know the syntax doesn't matter here
here's the bottom line
Trump did the right thing here he had to
fire her and it was clear she was going
to be fired from the minute that she
started doing this sort of immoral
preening while working for Trump it was
obvious that she was going to go the way
of the dodo bird in this job and from
spokesperson basically said that today
and from spokesperson is essentially
right now the Democrats are going nuts
over all this the Democrats are saying
this is the end of the world there
they're proof traying her as a hero
Chuck Schumer the Senate Minority Leader
he came out he said Yates is a Profile
in Courage this is a clip yeah you got
it and while they were going on of
course we had a Monday night massacre
Sally Yates a person of great integrity
who follows the law was fired by the
president she was fired because she
would not enact pursue the executive
order on the belief that it was illegal
perhaps unconstitutional it was a
Profile in Courage who's a brave act and
a right act president and his people who
were in the White House learned
something from this first that we are a
nation that's the rule of law and you
just can't so that what waiting here is
absolutely nonsense no it does not say
the ERR nation that respects the rule of
law when the Attorney General refuses to
do her job and defend in court measures
that are clearly constitutional and
clearly legal or at least arguably legal
what's what's interesting here is when
Schumer there are two things that are
interesting first of all when Schumer
suddenly says that it's a Monday night
massacre we'll talk about that in a
second is this akin to the Saturday
night massacre when Nixon essentially
fired his attorney general back in 1974
in the middle of Watergate is it like
that or is it not like that we'll talk
about that in one second the second
thing that he says here that's pretty
amazing is he says that she did the
right thing that she was saying that it
was unconstitutional and illegal she
never says that sadly it's never said
this was unconstitutional she never even
said it was illegal Sally AIT's
basically said I don't feel like
enforcing this so I'm not going to I
hate that kind of stuff in the state of
California we had the situation which
right with our now Senator Kamala Harris
when she was Attorney General out here
in the state of California Kamala Harris
this routine where she refused to defend
proposition 8 the people of California
voted for traditional marriage and it
didn't make a difference to her she just
refused to defend it in court until
proposition 8 basically was struck down
by the Supreme Court on the grounds that
no one was willing to defend it that was
gross it was her job to defend it
whether or not she agreed with it when
your job is to do something whether or
not you agree with it it's your job to
do it now it's amazing the left is
saying that this is just great heroism I
remember when they thought that Kim
Davis remember her she's a kid the
Kentucky County Court Clerk who refused
to sign same-sex marriage licenses and
issue them and told her aides not to do
it and actually threw her in jail for
refusing to do that because they
couldn't fire her because she was
elected so instead they threw her in
jail and people on the Left said that
was totally fine of course they should
throw her in jail there's a stronger
case for Kim Davis than there is for
Sally Yates here because the fact is
that Yates doesn't even contend this is
illegal
at least Kim Davis was saying it's
unconstitutional for the Supreme Court
to basically write same-sex marriage
into the Constitution in any case the
state obviously had the authority to do
to deal with Kim Davis and obviously
Trump has the authority to do what he
did with Sally aide so as far as the
Watergate thing first of all I think we
should quote here Carl Bernstein Carl
Bernstein was one of the reporters as in
Woodward and Bernstein who investigated
Watergate he says trying to like and
what Trump just did to Sally aides to to
what happened at the Saturday massacre
is ridiculous for people who don't know
the Saturday massacres in 1973 Richard
Nixon demands the firing of the
independent prosecutor Archibald Cox in
the Watergate investigation and then
when the AG Elliot Richardson and deputy
AG guy named William Ruckelshaus refused
to fire him he fires both of them right
that's called the Saturday night
massacre Carl Bernstein says no this is
not like that do you think that that she
needed to go there's a big difference
because the Saturday night massacre was
really about firing the Attorney General
when Nixon was the target of an
investigation and was actively
obstructing justice I think the
president is within his within his right
here to fire the Attorney General that
he has that ability and it's not wise
that he did but what's really happened
here is
the president and his presidency is in
chaos and it's apparent to all but his
most serious defenders and those who are
his greatest defenders and advocates but
for Republicans on Capitol Hill who I'm
talking to who are doubting his
abilities doubting even his stability
under pressure this is an extraordinary
series of events we now have hundreds of
thousands of people who had been going
into the street as a result of their
relevant what Bernstein says about the
Monday night massacre is relevant it's
not like the Saturday massacre it's
Saturday night massacre again was
pursued because Archibald Cox was
subpoenaing the Nixon tapes and Nixon
said no and I'm gonna fire you
and then he once was AG and his AG's
head knows who fired the AG so as an
attempted cover-up now was it legal for
Nixon to do it actually it was it was
absolutely legal for Nixon to fire the
Attorney General and in fact there's a
solid case to be made that all of these
independent prosecutor laws are actually
unconstitutional this is a case that
Justice Scalia made back in the 1980s he
said there's a unitary executive right
the Constitution doesn't say anything
about there being an investigative
Council some independent counsel who
gets to Rove around investigating the
President of the United States in fact
this is what Democrats were saying when
Kenneth Starr was doing it under the
Independent Counsel Act which is why
they allowed it to expire so there have
been long-standing constitutional and
legal questions about whether you ought
to have independent counsel doing this
but she's not even independent sally
Eights isn't even independent okay so
she's actually the AG and so the AG does
not get to tell the president that she
just doesn't feel like enforcing the
stuff that's law that's that's silly
again it's not unprecedented it's not
like the Saturday night massacre and it
is totally legal all of it is totally
legal alan dershowitz says this to Alan
Dershowitz the the he's a Democrat I've
taken class with him at Harvard Law
School and the professor Dershowitz says
obviously he had every capacity to fire
this this deputy this acting Attorney
General it's a political decision
there's an enormous distinction between
green card holders on the one hand
people who are in the country and have
to be thrown out on the second hand
and people who are simply applying to
get visas there is also a distinct in
what's constitutional what's statutorily
prohibited what's bad policy this is
very bad policy
yeah what's lawful and I think by
lumping all of them together she has
made a political decision rather than a
legal one and he's exactly right and
because it's a political decision not a
legal one that person should be fired
right I mean that's then and so she was
fired the media are using this as an
opportunity to bash Trump but that's not
fair to Trump it's it's actually a
ridiculous criticism of Trump it doesn't
make a whole hell of a lot of sense now
as that goes on the Democrats are using
anything as an excuse to try and hold up
anything Trump wants to do which is kind
of shocking if they were smart what
they'd do is go along with the stuff
they like from Trump and then fight him
on the stuff they don't like but there's
a mandate now from the donors that they
are going to just bash Trump at every
opportunity so today they're a bunch of
Democrats who walked out of their
various committees in order to try and
hold up the Treasury secretary
nomination of Steve minuchin I'm not a
big minuchin fan but that's ridiculous
it's not going to work also what game do
you get from this what game do you
obtain from blocking Trump's cabinet
nominees it's one thing to vote against
them it's another thing to not even give
them an up or down vote in the cabinet
specifically because I mean like what
did they think that he's gonna come back
with a Democrat or somebody even more
democratic than minuchin who's a
lifelong Democratic donor like what are
they aiming for here
it's really quite ridiculous they're
also talking about filibustering Trump's
judicial nominee they've said that
they're gonna filibuster it all along
I've been contending for a year a full
year that they were going to filibuster
Trump's judicial nominee and that it was
dicey whether Mitch McConnell was going
to invoke the nuclear option whether
Mitch McConnell was actually the Senate
Majority Leader was actually going to
invoke what they call the nuclear option
that means that you take a straight vote
on whether to close the whether to
change the filibuster rule you get rid
of the filibuster and then you vote on
the Justice himself it's not clear
whether McConnell is willing to do that
at all which is why my prediction is and
I could very well be wrong I've been
wrong before my prediction is that
tonight Donald Trump is probably going
to nominate Thomas Hartman of the
Seventh Circuit in Pennsylvania because
he's the most self candidate he's the
guy who we know least about and I'll
explain in just a second why I think
that's a bad
well we should actually be demanding of
the Supreme Court nominee and what we
should be demanding of Trump and what we
should be demanding of the Republican
Senate in just a second but in order for
you to see that you have to go over to
Daley wired.com and become a subscriber
eight bucks a month allows you to see
the rest of the show live you become
part of the mailbag we have a lot more
coming up on today's show annual
subscribers get a free signed copy of my
book true allegiance we also have a
Shapiro store that's coming with some
really cool gear I keep promising it I
promise it is actually going to happen
it's not just a myth
and and so that will be coming very soon
with some goodies there so go to daily
wear calm to become a subscriber and
join us we are the largest conservative
podcast in the United States
[Music]
you